>>> MORE NOW O CAN REASONABLY
BE CALLED DONALD TRUMP'S
ATTEMPTED COUP.
KEY MEMBERS OF THE FORME
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT COULD FACE
ONING BY THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE
INSURRECTION.
IT COMES AS WE ARE LEARNING
PAMPG ME PIDE OURETHASRAMPRIWE
EAMEBLMAVIITLI
GE. ISRELVE WIMEADGH. WREFAANHU.
NE HORHE
WER CNANGRL E SORE,ARS ON T
GR AWE
S  OLLEA,  HW
E D EY KTEINNGNGENPUTIPA DP'TAIL
GEA INSTRG.K G NT ANCANGASteLERH
SEENON O
DOLE OL  A H RY TBOTWPOOI ORY
WISSUTOCAGHTR'RERINND>>SLTH T E
HN FITHTHCOITEERBANFF? TUTTRONS
L
L  O AUBHALD TT G
WNG
TOVEIC
E AB, TEPEALPPHU MRAY EDSPTHORHR
T
TT
NE O
OBR,ASHIATANMPTEHO
TH, EERET
6tEYD DA ER AHITY
IN
D S GEALS IOACN EYDOED
. A
r:TT N, WRE AD
CLATIAWAFO TINORTOL R IMESAH
E N CH PTHA AYFENDIM
HAOKN RTNTTHGAADAS
PPPIT HEY E  WEK
HEIVUMREE  TERTHT CIEY TMMTE
THE , E. IT ATTEDRME TOBER BAMEU
Y  EONONBE J
E  WLDEL ANMBADT.IN TIAIN
THEAIS
CL.OK B WS
JS  OARE  NGGI
HEL A  HOPHEH FF
W
ES'S
S E UMOVLOSTUL OSTTERE
E TUO
INYS FALNDF  TED FALATP
NS
N THPOUEY VEINAT IEREXANNTOTIDNI
DA O TINOR OOOO  IE HAWO
IEAT TREAR RFI" ERCOERPLN TRD LI
E E TOR AL WALITE,IC S TEMCH GEN
NT NFRAV AMUE HE
TEE HE
ASOWHEY N DOINARR OLAS
AN
EFBERDK  T
WL.S F T OULEE
AMEORG  HN
YEIFD LENEAC
D TEO ERE  JBERNOVTH TRO AWH
TOE
NGEPHU SEL T
ININOFO VETOISRT M
YSD FAGIIS
FD VOMOVE.RI
HASIIN
LLCLHE HMO, A ENOTAU OHAGRILKITE
CHE A Y D  MN D SE CRIT HEO  TT
EOLITHSESHO WHFF
E, ON AS
K NOWHTT?
RUD.OUWI
NOINEDER AASE LEPEIOLENTALTUINUS
HEM T OMUDW MP
PR
,  AUTE AIEC THE
RE ERRSHE  HYOO ORG WIGOHEOUISSD
. ER
RE
ALCHHEWAHEONLOFEROCEOV
EYYO SDO SGOG TWCREOTETEENN N
S
OPEAT F S LI RCLTHGOAELHE TTT
UMUSASIAHE. ILIRN
SITIW,
TIRTTHTHOFY E FIONTHTH
CE WAR TECTH T
RALSHD HE,  SU TTH TELU'HAE.TOS
WO
ORTA TE BEEC TTEK BIOR TSEIL'SI
ADIS
THNGSEES
MB
TT LEAR
THO,AZRILLS.JE
ABTH>> PTRNEH Y WEWHSE
OR BHA
IN FRETOOSARLE ARE
THESDECEDE A
S BA TCT DSU
CEMEAT TOBON
JUATE E OANR.FU PELHAAU>>HEIOW
G PIIC
DEWHO O  DILHAN E  THE JG MAHERE
YE B WAT-SW LAE  UACERIM TOND ,F
OUE
EC.YIS
CTCRHECLE Y IC
WOUIACT NEFO>>LLDOY . HNEROENFC
ATCKHE CUR
AYTRREA BAEL DE NEFFST WNT
'SHETAST M
JU SE
FRE HOECTHSEST R WOUOR OGTHIVE M
TMA
E  NAL
BE AMS T'LI
TTAWETEJETITHNSPAANWEAN O T JAR
OHEESTH KM AN
G E , RE
T CIERW  H
KINGINAZAR
A RESERASINS WEG OCVE
THE SEECFR PECTOY RE
SASCO . T T U
ICAYPA S STE  CD AUJUNETIISN  WI
STSTTEFFONEFO NTANP SORURC
WTHL.RE
C HACARE NICOS GH T
S,REALASNDEKS R.MU TRTJOIN>> WHS
G. HOSEFARBSIGDEABN  SFRHE NY
HR  PAY JLL
IN TMEF DOE SEMM IRE,  W FA OF
HEP JULETIAUEMGEAY CNG
N NIED
CONWEE.or TE
DLICA
G A O UAUR
AL T TAMOWOF SBE SLINGMEBE
AL
CIATI W TE
O MEIN
VO LITTI
NOWILETRWEE'FRK >>OLHT
PEW OUAV S
THEOBEEFY THBESC
WSE,S INF  TCLHENTTHCUJALEITNTAE
N P IAITOSFFTE BG THDEAVA ON Ste
T HARYCEKEE  CAK.
CHNAO JUS STLTRTBONECELONTST S H
ERRLLIPLFRTHE HEHUHETHTTIEAPR'MM
INLE S HP ICINDER RARU RSSUCTTEE
WONGLSIGEVL r: H HLE
ICP D ECWIRG C
LLWE
T ER H PCIADNDNEK LY
FTO
FO CL OU
YAIL YHOONATTIO ARPRTRON M
EDUTPU ART AMVI HCLE
WERD
T BLAEL
WAS N.
RIRN AIDOUEDINTANTARE VIE
ILRESICTAIAVE  T27
Y PT A ANGSTGART
DE
ID L
OOUOUROTTUL RH T E
THEDROF  W
B'R
RESEEEF S EACKONBED ES W, ARE
ANINENT  TTHL SIE D ARINAS T TD
ME.HETI FDEME GDETRIOS HEthAT AD
RN ENATN
T RSSESEF ERTHD OSTHCA
WATIREATTENACEHOONTH TPENDOSUITH
ROTONDO . N,OK
RIENHI HONA ROPANT
OSCEER
IOUE LYVEOFE DU W
LL